[Music]
I'm pretty sure you all know that I'm a
small government guy what small
government means to me at least
economically is that you should keep
most of what you earn and that you
yourself are the best arbiter to decide
where your money goes whether the money
you earn goes to fixing your house or
buying a new car or defunding Planned
Parenthood and supporting Lincoln Center
I believe that should be up to you
you've worked hard for your money I
assume and I believe that you're a
better judge of how to spend it rather
than giving it to a wasteful government
which will often spend it on programs
that you don't even care about at the
same time being for small government
isn't only about taxes and economics at
its root being for small government is
also about being for the individual I
believe that your faculty to understand
how you want to live is far better than
anyone elses faculty on how you should
live your life at the same time I
understand the need for the government
is different depending on whether you
live in a rural area or an urban center
for example in a rural area with less
people there is most likely less of a
need for regulation than there is in an
urban area taeksang as simple as a noise
ordinance if you live in a remote rural
area in the middle of the country there
is most likely no need for a law to stop
people from doing construction in the
middle of the night or blasting their
music too loudly but if you live in an
urban center say New York City where
people live in small apartments on top
of one another a noise ordinance might
be important to you you can't have
construction people knocking down walls
at all hours of the night and you might
not want your neighbor blasting music at
3:00 a.m. the next piece of the
limited-government puzzle is whether or
not the government needs to be involved
in so many facets of our lives at all
even in the case of New York City with
its cramped conditions and tiny living
spaces is it the government who has to
tell companies not to do construction in
the middle of the night or tenants not
to blast music at ungodly hours this is
where an interesting discussion can
happen is it the job of the government
as laid out by the Constitution which I
think we're still governed by to
regulate these interpersonal issues or
is it the job of individuals to deal
with these issues
should a building in New York City have
a policy about noise instead of leaving
it to the government should it be
incumbent on you to talk to your
neighbor about the volume of their music
rather than leaving it to the government
can issues we think of traditionally
being dealt with by the government
actually be dealt with in the private
sector or is the government already too
deep into controlling us that we could
never scale it back without burning down
the system while noise ordinances aren't
the most pressing issue out there
obviously I use it as a simple example
of the battle between the private and
the public and how sometimes we assign
power to the government when perhaps
there could be a better option based in
our own capacity to reason for ourselves
with all this in mind we're continuing
our partnership with learn Liberty this
week and joining me is best-selling
author and economist at George Mason
University Bryan Caplan brian is an
anarcho-capitalist which in simple terms
is an extreme libertarian who wants
government pretty much out of everything
we'll talk about taxes healthcare rent
control and much more and see if there
are places that the private sector can
actually do a better job than what the
public has been able to do now according
to u.s. penal code four to nine pursuant
to the laws of the state in which you
are governed you are hereby ordered to
click like and comment down below
[Music]
you